so I'm in charge of this panel I'm your
moderator for this very interesting
panel that we put together with some
notable names from the Python and open
source community as well as some folks
from Microsoft the topic of our pallet
so our topic for this panel is how to
integrate open source into a large
corporate environment I'd like to start
by having all of the panelists introduce
themselves so we'll start with Steve my
name is Steve della I work at Microsoft
been here for about three years now I
also contribute to see Python and have
been working on a project at Microsoft
that's been open source the entire time
I've been here which is the Python tools
for visual studio I'm Brian Granger and
I'm a professor at Cal Poly one of the
lead developers and leaders of Jupiter
and I Python and also an unfocused board
member my name is mark Wiebe I'm with
pink box software we create visual
effects software primarily I've
contributed to numpy and started the
diné project my name is Brett cannon
I've been a cork attributed to Python
for about 12 years now I've been working
at Microsoft for two weeks less than two
months ago I left Google after having
been there for about four years so this
panel is somewhat open ended in format
but I'd like to start with some personal
questions for Steve and Brett both of
who are Microsoft employees and both are
who are our open source contributors
Brett as many of you know is a longtime
contributor to see Python and I believe
you were brought into this role with
full knowledge that you're a contributor
with full knowledge that part of your
role here at Microsoft would be
contributing to C Python yes to the best
of my knowledge did you find in that
situation that you still had to
negotiate certain things internally in
order to work as freely with the open
source community as you work previously
no but honestly that's because in my job
hunt I made that a requirement I
personally chose to only speak to
companies where
I knew open source was being done for
instance I knew Steve was already here
and it was being allowed to on company
time to contribute to Python C Python
specifically so the only was a
prerequisite to speak to any potential
employer that they had to have that
culture now in place of allowing people
on paid time to work an open source if
that was going to be part of their job
so Steve your contribution of Microsoft
has been going on for a couple of years
now when you started working at open
source and Microsoft was this a role
that you had to create or a role that
was created for you so the role was
somewhat created for me i was actually
hired by microsoft on the basis of my
contributions to a project that was
already open source which was the visual
studio tooling was open source from
really early on through the strong
wishes of the program manager and that
who i believe i saw come in somewhere
right up the back so he's here in the
hat being inconspicuous yep everyone
have a look so the project that I I was
hired on to was already open source and
I was already making contributions
before being hired and so that was about
I'm in doubt that project was kicked off
sort of five six years ago and surely
and before that there had been a project
ironpython that most people are aware of
which Microsoft no longer has but that
project was also open source and was one
of the earliest open source projects at
Microsoft so there was some precedent
but it was nothing like it is today
there was a lot of challenges in keeping
those projects open and being able to
have contributions worked in you know in
a way that's less of a problem now so
contextualized in this fashion I think
the first topic that this panel is here
to discuss is how do we contribute to
open source at the individual level at
the level of individual developers
within a large organization contributing
to open source I think brian has some
experience on the ipython project in the
project Jupiter with contributors inside
organizations like Bloomberg and some of
the hurdles that they have to overcome
in order to make individualized
contribution to open source yeah so I
Python and
Jupiter have a core team that work
heavily on the project the size of that
team is about a dozen people and in
addition to that we have a larger halo
of contributors in the many hundreds
over the history of the project and I
would a good number of the core
contributors work at companies in
industry some of those companies are
sort of directly related to the the
Python data science scientific computing
space other companies like Bloomberg are
less directly related and I think one of
the big things we see is in many cases
it's a question of the culture in the
company yes there are sometimes legal
barriers involved in getting individuals
getting permission to contribute to an
open source project but in many cases it
really comes down to company culture an
example of this is a boston-based
startup cuanto peon that is building on
top of Jupiter and as part of their
company culture it's just a given that
they're going to use open source and
contribute back to it and so for us to
work with them the barriers were
extremely low it was more a matter of
saying hey we should do this we should
work together other companies don't have
that culture and so even simple things
like the idea that our project is on
github in any one of the world can fork
it and submit a pull request is a very
novel idea and it's not necessarily
illegal or a license or copyright or
patent issue it's more just a cultural
question of are they familiar with
working in this way so in order to
encourage some participation from the
audience I just like a show of hands how
many in the audience have tried to work
try to perform some sort of upstream
commit or substream patching from within
a corporate environment on work that you
are doing related to some corporate
initiative and how many of you have been
successful of that in that effort and
how many of you been unsuccessful so how
many have actually try
to contribute to open source as part of
your job within a corporate environment
how many of you have been successful in
that and how many of you have been
unsuccessful in that so what barriers do
we see for the folks up here who or for
the folks who've raised their hands and
have been unsuccessful these
contributions and how can we remove
those barriers how can we encourage
better contribution from corporate
entities so certainly one of the
barriers that exist at a Microsoft fur
for a long time was sort of a real
blockage on there is a license here that
we don't understand and so as soon as
the question sort of gets the lawyers of
house what license will this
contribution be under what implications
does that have for the rest of our
software you know if that developer has
looked at our code and looked at open
source code how does that interact and
that's the thing that Microsoft we've
certainly seen change over the years as
our legal teams have developed a better
understanding of the licenses involved
and being able to move through brief
periods of flirting with creating our
own licenses to looking at the OSA
licenses and saying well these ones are
very safe for us these ones are less
safe these ones need more investigation
need more work before we can be either
using or contributing to them and
basically a whole lot of things get
tried there just as far as isolating
developers who are using particular
licenses but we've reached a point now
where there's that list of licenses that
are problematic is really really small
because as we've worked through our team
our legal teams of work through
analyzing the licenses most of them are
have actually turned out to not be an
issue despite the fact that software is
our core product working with those
licenses using software under those
licenses and contributing to it in a lot
of cases has like looks more and looks
less and less like a concern so for
those of you in the audience or on the
panel who are packaged authors or
maintained errs who are owners of
projects
these difficulties in contributions from
within corporate ease affect your
funding model or your organizational
model since you can't rely on external
entities funding development of these
projects by the way this is a panel that
is open to members of the audience to
comment as well um so think box software
is fairly small and we don't have a lot
of resources to throw head open source
projects that don't necessarily directly
benefit us so we always have to play
that that game of like trying to figure
out if we contribute to an open source
project are we contributing something
that's kind of undercutting our core
business or is it going to benefit both
us or benefit us in such a way that it's
not something it's like making our life
better but it would be better to like
hand that off outside of our our own
development resources an example of
something that we introduced to the
world was we we made a file format for
particle files and we published a spec
and the end result of like having people
implement that was we found that we
really had to publish our own
open-source software to implement the
spec to make it easy for people to
integrate with what we were creating so
that was a way that we saw that like it
was an obvious win of interoperability
like between us and our customers and
other software vendors from a project
perspective at least for C Python one
challenge we have is no one on the team
is really paid to just do Python as an
open source project there's no one like
saying alright we're going to hire
person X and their job is Larry just to
do whatever they feel they need to do
for Python and keep it healthy and or
whatever they want to do so it tends to
cause
projects that could potentially be very
long-term to take longer and not
necessarily be counted as necessary aren
t going to happen because you can't say
all right he's if it's going to take a
week they don't say have five full days
eight hours a day to do this they're
just going to have their evenings in
their weekends and so it tends to lead
to some questions of potential planning
and just availability and just focus and
just knowing that this is actually going
to happen in real life is not going to
get in the way because someone's kids
sick on the weekend and that's their
weekend time for pythons now gone and
now that's blown out a week or a month
or whatever people go on vacation and so
it really kind of shifts focus and
long-term planning in terms of what's
possible and then the flip side of that
is when you do get a company that's
willing to pay an employee full time to
work on Python day as Mark said they do
have some vested interest it's like it
has to make business sense for the
company to do that in most cases which
is why you get someone from Microsoft
working on the windows side of Python
and whereas people from other companies
Rackspace sponsor a lot of Python
developers are not coming in with the
same focus and the same this is
supporting like this is supporting
project while also supporting our
business because you have that extra
dynamic in there of you are being paid
by someone and that someone then has
some entitlement to control what your
contributions look like I'm sure Brian
seen that as well as corporations want
to contribute towards Jupiter is it
worth trying to encourage this at a
company with tens of thousands or maybe
even hundreds of thousands of employees
is a worth encouraging those
organizations to allocate some small
number of employees for the pure purpose
of advancing these open source projects
distinct from some business deliverable
well I'm bias I'm just gonna say yes but
I mean that's cuz because my position on
a big project that's used by who knows
how many people driving how many
billions of dollars across the world I'm
it's just a tough sell right it's one of
these you have to convince people that a
project such as Jupiter or Python is
such a core piece of York
bini that you don't need to drive
certain feature requests you need to
just make sure the project survives you
need to care about its health and its
vibrancy and its community to the extent
that we just have to pay someone just to
keep guarantee no matter what happens
the project keeps going I mean and you
see this happened in certain companies
right like companies that produce
software just to make sure that if some
other company collapses they're going to
be okay and have their rears covered
right I mean a famous example is google
chrome I google chrome to be faster but
also made sure that if something
happened to Firefox or whatever they had
their browser to make sure that you
could still get to their products and
this is true of open source is just
taking time for certain companies to
realize that certain projects at certain
levels of the stack have the exact same
needs so for instance Linux completely
has discovered like people contribute to
the Linux Foundation linis Torvalds
basically as tenure as the Linux kernel
manager and that's all taken care of it
it's just other projects in certain
variant levels of exposure do or don't
get coverage so for instance you guys
were did great jobs and got got your
grants for Jupiter and so there's
funding there and you guys have coverage
and you can make sure the project keeps
going it's just making sure that certain
levels down such as Python being this
thing that's helping push these other
projects up is able to get that kind of
coverage the other problem is and I had
a discussion with fernando and brian is
just there's also a difference between
the academic world where this is kind of
built into the system in terms of
encouragement of getting grants and
keeping the software and doing this kind
of work versus once at enterprise as you
said where it's hard to convince people
that the basic vibrancy and support and
health of the project is enough to
support rather than we should do it but
we also want to make sure we have our
stuff covered too and covering that kind
of angle as well so I think actually the
interests of different companies pushing
into open source can be really
beneficial for those open source
projects to like in llvm you look at the
push to make compiler technology more
open
or ide type of technology and GCC was
not fulfilling that wish and that
motivated some contributions there
similarly adding different backends for
different CPU architectures like those
are interests of different corporations
that make the project better as a whole
oh yeah i didn't i sorry if anyone took
the suggestion that I didn't think those
kinds of reasons I mean what Steve is
done for windows installs has been
absolutely fantastic and it's great and
it's wonderful that Microsoft is paying
him basically if part of his work time
to actually make that happen it's
definitely adds contributions it gets
good coverage like we have input for
linux we have input for windows we make
sure that everything's going to work
cross-platform and no one's going to get
screwed and put in a bad position it
does help having certain having
different interests and viewpoints in
there definitely and and a recent one
that has come up for see Python recently
as Intel's really stepped up to
contribute some performance improvements
since like for their processes because
that is what they know inside out and I
don't know that we know their ulterior
motive if they have one yet so far its
original you they want pie three times
faster on intel processors I'm like okay
we're okay you came along with the patch
and said this makes it faster and the
benchmarks saying yes it made a fast
really great if you want to make Python
faster feel free for the sustainability
of an open source project is it a better
idea to try to cultivate come to
cultivate contributions from within an
organization or to just seek direct
funding for an external group so I think
I would I think it is a both/and and i
think the context there is that if open
source projects want to survive they
really have to structure themselves in a
very strategic way that many ways
resembles a commercial entity let's face
it i mean opens open source projects
have competition under what business
model if I destruction is a commercial
entity well
no I'm not suggesting that open source
projects become commercial entities I
think I'm more proposing that they think
of themselves in those same terms right
commercial entities and open source
projects have competition right our
users can go pick different languages
different libraries we have to to think
about funding I mean if funding for
these projects goes away and maybe that
funding is your own evenings and
weekends but that is a I mean time
equals money and so if you're spending
20 hours a week in the evenings and
weekends well you have to think about is
that sustainable a lot of us started to
work on open source when we were
students or postdocs and at that point
in our lives that type of time
allocation was very sustainable as you
get married and have kids that's not
very popular I mean it doesn't work very
well to say you go to the beach today
I'm gonna stay home in code all day and
so is what's that so that gives you but
while we're doing yeah some of ABS
absolutely and and so there's
competition and there's also customers
and I think the exact business model if
you want to call the business model that
an individual open source project
chooses to use it really depends on what
that landscape looks like for a project
like Jupiter we're getting a lot of
adoption from large companies right now
and so we are in fact seeing companies
hire full-time developers that work with
all of their official company time on
our project we also have users in the
academic research space and so private
foundations who are support supporting
those other projects have a keen
interest to make sure that we succeed
and so I think it all depends i'm ii
just like any company that starts has to
think about well who are our customers
what what problems are we solving for
them and then framing the business model
around that open source projects need to
do the same thing even though they're
not selling something
or I should say the thing they're
selling is free however you want to
phrase it yeah I agree it is both
because they both solve different
problems right gaming a company devote
time and energy to contribute is great
but then the money can also then go to
foundation size of the Python Software
Foundation which then helps foster the
community which is helps or to numb
focus which allows hi-data to happen and
I think they just serve two different
purposes because the money is much more
fun ghable fungible in terms of what it
can be put towards wildman port
typically is more focused I mean you
could potentially have someone who's
more like community volunteer and work
on community specific stuffs but
typically business companies it's much
harder to convince them to do that and
unless it's ads like developer relations
and such but I think both contribute in
their own special ways so moving on oh
we have some questions from the audience
can we get a microphone to them yeah
it's right in your earlier point any
suggestion for projects where the are
that mode where the original core group
developers have gotten older they're no
longer willing to put in you know tons
of hours of personal time how do you
manage that to keep a sustainable
project going well at least for the way
it works for core python is we
constantly keep an eye out for people
who become active on the issue tracker
and people who seem to consistently just
be productively contributing and we just
typically reach out to them and say hey
you're doing some great comments on the
issue tracker would you like to get
developer privileges where you can start
editing the metadata on bugs and then
usually go yeah that'd be great then we
give it to them and they start doing
more more they start to could reap a
tchas make comments and code reviews and
if they keep that up we people tend to
notice and then they go oh hey you know
what you're doing so well why don't we
just give you the keys and let you just
do what you need and just stop that must
be a bottleneck so it's just it's just
part of the process for a project is
just to keep your eye out for new talent
that comes for
because it's it's it's just constant the
projects around long enough as Brian
point out you get students you get
people who just do this in their spare
time they just you just come in at
different times in their lives and just
come and contribute and you get them I
mean for instance we had Benjamin
Peterson become a court developer while
he was still in high school so we
snatched him early but I mean that
that's but that was happens right now
he's getting older and now he's starting
to be able to say oh yeah we should get
true rights for other people and just
you just become cyclical and then people
just kind of fall off but then these
people who came on earlier now becoming
the people who are not handing out the
rights and just kinds of virtuous cycle
as long as you stay on top of it the
other thing that we see with C Python at
least is as contributors get older and
and sort of get to Brett's age they get
to start negotiating with new companies
to get that that time allocated to work
on things so some of the longest-serving
contributors of C path and have
negotiated time with their employers and
basically said I am known like I'm
basically famous for working on C Python
and i will come work for you if you let
me have twenty twenty-five fifty percent
time for Python and there's a number of
core developers who have been doing it
for a long period of time that are able
to make those arrangements with new
employers and sometimes with current
employers and so they are able to get
that time in a more official capacity
rather than doing it on the spare time
as they become more senior and more
well-known for it or they just
integrating the specific jobs they apply
for so first is Barry works I was a very
good example he works for a boon to and
helps maintain Python for a boon to and
Debian so he just as part of his job
just works on Python and that whole
ecosystem and as part of that gets to
contribute right back because he finds
problems he's having at work gets to
that back is as part of it and it just
becomes once got another cycle of just
doing his normal job which then lets him
actually contribute directly so the the
project dined that i've started i think
is at a very early stage of that and
what we're working towards is trying to
get the so it's it's a fairly ambitious
in similar to dump I trying to define
standards and
sort of data layouts and a library
around that that can be used like numpy
but from C++ and other languages and
that needs to get to a certain level of
functionality to be able to like catch I
think there's a it's not quite there yet
and so within think box that's not
currently a color thing for us but I'm
trying to influence internal a some
directions of products and things to
make it possible that we contribute to
the project as well and so I think it's
it's like after you get past that
hobbyist phase it it's like stuff like
I'm doing irwin contributor is getting
support from continuum contributing to
the project that that kind of thing is
what i think will work for dined in the
end just one one quick comment on on
this topic of switching questions is
that I think our projects and with
Jupiter were actively trying to do this
is we need to get a little bit more
aggressive in seeking to seed and feed
that pipeline of people not just waiting
for that pipeline to feed itself by
virtue of serendipity and so seeking
defeated by virtue of training students
by creating the conditions for that to
be possible by engaging by doing
outreach by lowering the barriers in
those barriers or have many many forms
but but just waiting for that to be for
that pipeline to just kind of by
happenstance feed itself is is I think
insufficient if we want an ecosystem of
the complexity that we're beginning to
reach to really be be sustainable and to
tackle the kinds of challenges that
we're starting to face because one or
two small projects 10-15 years ago in
isolation was one thing I think our
ecosystem is starting to be something of
a scale of a complexity of being used in
tasks of a level of difficulty that
happy happy happy random serendipity
isn't going to be enough so there's a
persistent question as to the value of
sprints and hackathons there's a lot of
energy around hosting them but there
seem to be the very edge the widest part
of the funny what do the narrower parts
of the funnel look like so we both
Fernando and I have the benefit of being
at universities and so we I would say we
have a narrow part of the funnel where
we actively recruit students at those
universities and spend a long time like
literally training one or two students
over you know a multi-year period and
and you know really bringing them up
teach him teaching them the development
process the software tools and that is a
very deliberate and calculated effort
that we put into grant applications and
is an official part of our strategy with
that so this isn't for our open source
projects but think box has a great
success with co-op programs like more
than half of our developer employees
came through a co-op program and that's
a great way to get people interested in
your project and teach them kind of the
way that you you do things from a
company of your company wanting
developers on projects you support
there's an issue going way way back that
Brian mentioned about the parallel
between what happens in the commercial
world and what happens in the open
source world and one of the things that
happens in the commercial world is
concentration of wealth and resources
into a few companies and that also
happens in the open source world and for
a very good reason my computer I can
only keep in my head about five
different packages in my you know at one
time and so I have to be very selective
about what I choose but what that
creates is a very long tail of projects
that only have one
contributor and have very little
prospect of ever succeeding and I have a
feeling that that tail gets longer and
longer and might fall off at some point
how does one prevent all the resources
in the open source world from coalescing
around a few projects and having all the
others die on the vine I think just
almost by definition the way open source
starts will prevent that from happening
for instance well so well so I
personally first since have multiple
projects that I'm like one of the only
core contributors or I started off and
just happen to organically get a couple
contributors and I still contribute to
them so that long tail I don't think is
really going to drop off and disappear
because I don't think commercial pushes
towards coalescing towards a single
thing is going to lead to people to stop
wanting to do hobby projects on the
weekend so that's what I mean by open
source is by definition just something
people typically do for love not for
money and it just happens that we've now
ended up in this space in this industry
where open source actually does generate
revenue for people and thus they decide
to spend money on it to help keep it
going I mean it's a very unique position
we've developed over I don't know what
you guys say 5 5 10 years since this is
all kind of sort of money being funneled
into open source like that so it's still
kind of new really compared to the
length of time that software is really
existed but I personally feel people
always want to spend stuff time on the
weekends kids in university and high
school will constantly still want to
just make their programs and toss them
up there and I don't think that's going
to despair now in terms of the actual
money specifically getting focused
towards individual projects it's going
to happen potentially and it's going to
honestly come down to whether or not
someone comes along and does a good job
and then suddenly the focus shifts I
mean you could have said the exact same
thing about pearl like back in the back
in the beginning of the 2000s like that
was the language and that's where all
the money should have been going and now
pearl isn't quite as big of a thing and
pythons picked up that slack it
it happened to Python if we're not
careful it's just things shift just like
in the commercial market and things move
around and nothing's set in stone and
this is why brian says we have to kind
of keep an eye on things and realize
there's competition and keep moving
forward making sure we foster our
community and realize we can't neglect
anything or else people will just walk
away so I think it's basically the long
tail will always be there based because
people will just want to do software and
just want to put it up for fun and in
terms of the coalition of money it's
possible but it can also shift around
very fluidly because it is just software
in the end and another aspect of this so
if there was a project in this community
that was that had the most resources its
Jupiter for sure and exactly what Brett
said is happening in that we have
full-time staff working on Jupiter but
every single one of those full-time
staff has numerous other open source
projects that are much smaller that have
maybe one or two developers and they
spend significant amount of time on that
and we encourage it we we really want
people to be doing that because we
recognize that without this long tail
Jupiter is really pretty useless right
if there was no libraries for people to
use when they open up their notebooks
well who cares and I I don't think this
we're the only project that does this
there's this sort of halo that have
activity that happens around these big
projects that in some ways is
responsible for that long tails health
and and so I think that definitely is a
dynamic that that happens in this
community
state to treat it though as a static
dynamic over time both of your comments
it's more like I think the recording
industry in the fusion of music over the
Internet it's meant that a few artists
make it extremely people and most
artists make it not at all so they can
only function as hobbyist musicians
which means they can't support
themselves doing their music which means
that their music can only be partially
done which means that Deborah is able to
break out of the shell and I think we're
being complacent if we think that that
same dynamic will happen there is
certainly an aspect of popular projects
at various points and and projects sort
of like the popularity lifting and so a
lot of people jump on board and over
time that may decline and so it's less
interesting for people certainly that's
how projects in the open source world
break out they do tend to come from one
person putting something up and someone
else gets excited about it and suddenly
you have two people working on it
because that motivates the first person
to keep working on it and you do get
that cycle and something like Python
like C Python will suddenly blow up and
has lots of contributors and then it's
about maintaining that momentum exactly
as you say like for a recording artist
if an artist puts out a massive hit
album and then doesn't follow it up
they're going to fall out of the public
view and so it is about keeping that
excitement going somehow and that that
and and we're back sort of at the
competition side of things you have to
keep the freshness coming you have to
keep the excitement about the project
coming and if you get complacent than
yeah you you look less interesting to
the population so less people are
interested in contributing and balancing
that with corporate contributions a lot
of people get into open source because
they don't want to contribute to like
they aren't satisfied with doing the job
that just paid to do to write the code
they just paid to do they want to do
something outside of that more exciting
than that and when a project that is
that starts off exciting like that if
that becomes sort of corporate funded
then that can lose
of that appeal and then the the you lose
the people who were contributing because
it's not like it's not a fun project now
it's someone's business we have
inquiries making of different examples
for that as well we have a question
actually probably a comment from the far
back from Peter hey yeah well so I think
I think fun projects can also be
businesses so I don't think there's a
necessarily a strict economy there but i
think there's there's a couple of things
convolve din the question is a very good
one and and one is sort of a an aspect
of the world that we live in which is
this concept of winner-take-all and and
that dynamic applies a number of these
different things recording studios music
games so many of these things and that
fundamentally I think tracks the overall
trend technology where by humans have a
finite amount of attention and then
there's a snowball effect there's a
socialization effect if you read only
websites ABC and I only read websites d
e f then we have nothing to talk about
is much more fun if we both are ed and
we can talk about that and eventually
that becomes larger and larger in our in
our interaction and if we have a third
friend who also does that there's a
natural just almost like a physics level
of the communication the social patterns
new people the internet is really
driving towards homogenous ation and
centralization of beacons of this kind
of thing so that winner-take-all sort of
thing doesn't just apply to software
applies to anything that's social which
because we're humans is everything right
so that is the dynamic that you're right
we do have to be aware of but but but
the layered into their I think some of
the some of the feedback or the
resistance that you're hearing here
about the natural stabilizing you know I
got scratched my own itch I'm gonna hack
on my own fun projects my spare time
kind of thing is that we don't you know
have to be very careful even as we're
criticizing or trying to critical of
that winner-take-all thing we have to
make make sure that we don't and I heard
this actually expressed in a very ugly
way one time at foo camp and it was this
idea almost the sentiment of you know
that we have a right to somebody's
attention and that's the thing about
Internet's so interesting is that you
have to always remember you don't have a
right to anyone's attention they can
always turn away thinking always check
out other project they always go do
something that they think is more
interesting than what you're doing and
so at this
time that we want to embrace diversity
of viewpoints of projects of music of
everything and we want to fight that
homogenize ation and I wouldn't take all
thing in the interest of diversity in
artistic interest and what not on the
other side we have to be very cognizant
of the fact that we must always be
useful to to Walter ourselves first you
know if you're open sourcing hacking
something you don't like you're probably
not gonna hack on a very long but as we
get users and as we create an ecosystem
community we we we have to always be
relevant to all these people and I think
one of the reasons python has succeeded
you know Brett sort of talked about this
about Pearl versus in the pythons
dominance and then in the data science
side of things you know the dominant
competitor for our at least I mean for
Python as clearly as is our and it's not
Ruby right but in the web space for a
long time it was Ruby or Python Ruby or
Python now both of these people are
looking at go and node and all these
other things right so but in each of
these ecosystem compete with we we we
have to you know the communities we
create and the way we organize on our
software all of these things are are i
think in python land tend to trend
towards pragmatism towards openness and
welcoming new contributors new ideas
welcoming businesses as well as open
source sort of folks and so there's not
there's an economy again not there's
dichondra to the t necessarily but but
that kind of ethos means that we have
strong confidence i think that the
Python community will that that long
tail as other people start doing
interesting things and as more people
adopt those projects come into the fold
right the doors always open and that's
that's one way that we se you know the
folks that are building projects or
building companies in the space that's
what we can assure that this community
stays fresh and stays eclectic and open
so at this point I'd like to invite
closing statements from our panelists
and some of our impromptu panelists from
the audience I'll deposit one question a
very loaded question for them to think
about then we'll give them a round of
applause let them think about this
question and then open for closing
statements why is it important to
support numb focus is a question I want
everybody to think about and let's give
you a round of applause and then we'll
hear their closing statements
so supporting i still have ended up with
a different eye crow phone I can't hear
myself now supporting them focus is a
really good way to not let as well as
supporting it from from a larger
corporation point of view where you may
have an interest in certainly Microsoft
has an interest now in seeing the Python
data science community as a whole raised
up one spot microphone just go with that
one they'd sing the whole paper and data
science community raised up and picking
a project out of that if Microsoft went
out and said we're going to support
pandas or we're going to support non-pay
inherently we like what we have sort of
some somewhat them in that there's the
more fungible financial resources but as
far as development support it's very
hard to have enough people or enough
time to say we want to support all of
these important projects and avoid
saying we want to pick a winner so it's
great having non focus as a conduit to
that where we can by supporting non
focus support all of these projects that
are involved without necessarily having
to pick a winner I think picking see
Pathan is a winner which is more or less
what we've done in that direction is
also lifting up the entire community but
non focus is certainly as far as
corporate sponsorship goes a way that we
can be involved and be supportive and
events like this and grants towards
projects like Jupiter without having to
necessarily pick a winner and threw
everything in on one particular project
at the expense of the others that are
also is important
so as we interact with more and more at
we being Jupiter and ipython more and
more large companies as they consider
using ipython and Jupiter in various
ways the biggest barrier to them
adopting in engaging with us is not
technical it's not a question of the
features we have or anything like that
it just pertains to the legal
infrastructure of our project and the
formal governance model and that is what
num focus provides and without that I
think the open-source projects in the PI
data community will continue to struggle
to really engage companies in meaningful
ways and I think that's an area of
growth that that we need to undertake as
a community and supporting num focus
directly affects that in a very concrete
way um so one big benefit num focus
gives to a company wanting to contribute
to a project is all the machinery is in
place the connections to the people that
can contributor all there so there's a
very low barrier to entry to just bump
up a project a little bit if you company
wants to contribute and they have to
allocate a developer or like find out
like okay where do we find developers
having num focus they're already having
figured out all that information and set
up all the infrastructure for getting
the money to the right people finding
new people getting people excited
contributing to that can give much more
impact more quickly than going at you're
on your own I don't have much to add
beyond what everyone said other than I'd
like people to give to num focus so this
conference keeps going so I can come
back next year
appreciate James given me a chance to
say something this is travis olyphant
one of the startup original board
members of them focus it's fortunately
being run by a much better group of
people these days people a little more
time you know none focus for me this
community this effort all and you can
just see it in the faces and the
personalities of all the different
people that are creating the wonderful
tools around us it's not it's bigger
than one company it's bigger than any
one person or even small group of people
so it's dumb focus gives a place a legal
entity to allow you to interface with
organizations that are also legal
entities I mean it just seen there's a
lot of companies want to participate and
I'm focused gives an opportunity for
those companies to come together it's a
beautiful opportunity it needs a lot
more so many of you can go and influence
your companies to donate and I'm focus i
encourage you to do that please do that
if you're ever grateful for anything
ever did in sci fi a numpy just do that
and you'll repay me in multiple spades
do that the other thing you can do
though is just get involved personally
and I'm focus maybe you don't have big
influence with put the check writers
there are still people that they need
help Lea and she finally got one other
full-time person working for an
unfocused Gina and she's had a host of
other volunteer the board has volunteer
everybody else's volunteer but there are
a lot of needs just giving the website
updated keeping messaging going out so
just get involved there's all kinds of
committees to jump in and be involved
with and I'd like to thank James for
doing such a great job in doing exactly
that
my name is fernando pérez like Travis
and one of the original founders of Nome
focus and also like Travis not anymore
on the on the board for the same reasons
and to try to complement what the others
have said better than I would i want to
emphasize a couple of things that non
focus goes beyond actually the PI data
ecosystem then focuses a foundation
whose mission is software that is
related to scientific research and
education in the data science space but
we host the julia team we host the are
open science project we are a very
inclusive foundation that really is
interested in projects that interoperate
around the data science space so even
though many of us come from the Python
background we have really a very
inclusive view of the problem so and
that's that's important because in many
many of you may be in in environments
where there's more than Python to the
story and number two none focuses
mission also goes beyond software and
this is important unfocus has a very
strong interest not only in thinking
about the specific individual software
tools that we develop it also about
questions such as education the
diversity of our community outreach to
women in technology outreach to
communities that have been traditionally
underrepresented and the health of the
broader ecosystem non focus has many of
our tools come from traditionally as has
been said already academic research
environments National Labs numeric was
maintained for a long time the
predecessor to Nam pie from the
International labs and so now focuses a
bridge between the academic communities
the sort of government research
communities and Industry and it's a very
good space to kind of explore that
intersection in ways that some of the
other sort of pure industry foundations
don't quite touch so in that sense we
think that none focus is really a
foundation that is extremely interesting
and rich and complex and we would like
you to help us continue building as and
I will emphasize what Travis said if you
can't write checks there's many other
ways in which we can help us my name is
Lorena Barbara and I'm a professor of
mechanical and aerospace engineering in
the George Washington University and I'm
also a board member of non focus
and well my fellow board members have
said most of what I could have said as
well about the roles of non focus but I
want to just add an explanation for
those who might not realize that all of
the small projects in the Python
community are not able to collect money
from SS projects so that if you don't if
you're not aware of what the mechanism
is what num focus provides is for this
projects to be under the law able to
receive money without the Internal
Revenue Service being mad because of
course you can't just as a small project
collect money you know there's got to be
some organization that does it for you
in this case the num focus nonprofit
organization is able to collect money on
the name of all the project and in
addition run these other very important
community building activities such as
the Women in Technology programs and so
on and this is a very important role for
the sustainability of all the projects
that we rely that we know and love and
in addition it's a manifestation of our
democracy because we it is run in a
democratic way it is self organized and
like Travis said people are volunteering
and participating to provide governance
through this organization and it checks
out what I call I would have well I
stole it from somebody but I've adopted
my GPS to yes which is you have a good
time you meet wonderful people and
there's a wonderful community and you
develop your skills these are the three
things three reasons why we're in the
Python community why we're here as well
and non focus helps us organize and keep
that alive so I've asked for our last
closing comment are closing astore most
nearly closing comment to come from one
of the gentlemen who have made this
event possible stroke with your closing
statements okay no pressure there
actually I'll make it very simple
if you look at the spectrum of software
that the num focus organization in one
way or another directly or indirectly
has produced and how much benefit
Microsoft and companies like Microsoft
are getting from it I just feel a very
strong obligation for us to pay back now
you can do this in different ways I mean
right now we can take out our checkbook
and do that we've had employees that
like I said that the people said before
are contributing to the open-source
efforts in one way or another focus on
Python and I did a back of an envelope
calculation I think we've spent about a
million bucks in donations in one form
or another pretty much focused on Python
in the past five years so so this is
something that that we should do we
should pay back now we're going to find
different avenues to pay back and
support numb focus it's a very noble
committee of people in terms of the
direction that they're going and very
very high quality technology that is
being used in in all aspects of you know
our company from from Visual Studio all
the way to Azure in our SDKs and we want
to see that expand I want to see Python
become the scripting language that
cross-platform scripting language for
our cloud right now everything is
focused on net but now that we support
linux and windows i love for python to
become that that language and in that
technology therefore you know with with
numb focus being in a very center of
that universe i feel a strong obligation
to support them in any way possible and
i encourage everybody else to do that
thank you thank you so much and one last
round of applause for all of you for
attending and all of our panelists thank
you so much for them
you